now that we know what a matrix is let's
see if we can start to define some
operations on matrices so let's say i
have the 2 by 3 matrix so 2 rows and 3
columns and the entries are 7
negative 10 3
and 0
and i want to define what happens when i
multiply 3 times this whole thing so
first of all let's get a little
terminology out of the way
the number 3 in just the everyday world
if you weren't dealing with matrices or
vectors and if you don't know what
vectors are don't worry about them just
now you would just call that a number or
you would call this a real number it's
just a regular number sitting out there
but now in the world where we have these
new structured things these matrices
these these arrays of numbers we will
refer to these just plain old real
numbers that aren't part of some type of
an array here we call these scalars
we call this we call this a scalar so
essentially what we're defining here we
don't know we haven't i haven't said
what this is actually going to turn out
to be but whatever this turns out to be
will be a product of scalar
multiplication or we're multiplying a
scalar times a matrix and so how would
you define this what do you think this
should be three times this stuff right
over here
well the world could have defined scalar
multiplication however it saw fit but
one way that we find perhaps most
obvious and most useful is to multiply
this scalar quantity times each of the
entries so this is going to be equal to
3 times 7 in the top left 3 times 5
3 times negative 10
three times three
three times eight
and three times zero
which will give us it didn't change the
dimensions of the matrix it didn't
change i guess you could say the
structure of the matrix it just
multiplied each of the entries times
three so the top left entry is now going
to be 21 the middle entry or the the
middle the entry in the middle row top
column is going to be 15
negative 30
and 0.
so when you multiply a matrix times a
scalar you just multiply each of those
entries times that scalar quantity